[Musica]
oddio salvagenti per dire prendersi
realizzare il libro metti all'inizio del
video ragazzi oggi oggi una realtà
difficile proviamo a fare un 1 v1 io e
lowry gis
ma rideteci prova e buona buona buona
visione
non lo facciamo cattivo va bè ragazzi si
parte col 1b 1 contro non solo
laurentiis centro molto piano caronti
proprio parsa la madonna che figle
propria produzione della carta forno una
proveniente da produce airbus il booster
se si procederà il bus va bene
si parte sempre che fai dove stai ormai
ero morto ormai era andato ormai era
fatta non sa che non ho mai fatto una
voce nel senso non so come si giocano
devono vivono stanzialmente mondo ma il
bologna gioco poker nel modo migliore
per migliorare maggio come mio zio ma il
televoto come un cavallo spinto a te
beh allora impegnati la sua massima
potenza gli impegni la massima potenza
vedete cosa succede
sicuro no dopo sta bene come la parata
burocrazia gatti neri mistral di un
pochino sito se dice non mi aspettavo
proprio lui basta il video finisce qua
siamo una due e potrebbe essere onesto
come risultato la finale umiliante ora
salvato mega in alto ad esempio non è
vero che esiste questa cosa sta regola
un arbitro il suo gioco porco demonio un
arbitro chi vedo 80 agli ex proprio lui
la parola sente viva dai grazie al bus
incredibile no è indubbiamente tu che mi
è stato detto non ci metti la zona
99 vasumi cargo eccolo
no non lo hai fatto alto non è una donna
vive la ristorazione con nervoso mi
chiesto smash andò dai cam cam o no no
no no non controlla ridotti ride
ultimato dai cacchio l'ho aspettato fino
all'ultimo porco demonio posso perdere
capital in guida si sia per niente si
accetta non riesco più a parlarsi anche
più faccia temi diversi
ma dai però io ero attraversa ed entra
la mia porta possono fare uno che vuole
signore tanto vado in predict però
nonostante questo i gol non c'è la
raffinata pure sono ciao ciao
non è possibile come dai per questo ma
un attacco che sono sento me lo sento
meno sento ma dove cacchio vado ma non
gas sale
vabbè ok in controllino il tiro diretto
cioè in open
addio salva jarvi per dire play maker
iniziano il video mettila all'inizio del
video per il con io che dico mettere in
servizio per favore va bene tutto giusto
e allora questa era questa relazione è
piaciuta calcolare ma no però 27 t be
rock tv la tv la traversa voglio vedere
esattamente se tutti impegni al massimo
ma per la scienza che cosa succede e
dondoli proprio che non devi farci è
come se si giocando nel tour anche io
faccio la stessa cosa fai
le scotte picchino clicchino cli chi non
ha proprio senso tanto va bene ok ok di
mi sono mai calcolata questa cosa no e
allora che capii se avevi calcolata
sulla premazzi ha ricevuto di vincere
vittima nonché la nove semi synergy zano
anche le sfighe ho finito c'è già è uno
scontro impossibile
va bene questo ok con sbagliato ma
perché c'ero
obiettivo che brutto tocco no niente non
suscita però niente non so demolito va
bene non è su persone ero su personale
abbiamo visto gioco ben 38 la guarda
guarda guarda smash ha votato anche il
computer ma dai palo interno collo aveva
già dovuto provare devo trovare anche il
gol dove l'evento in tutto e per tutto
il film è dentro
no perché sono io e terziaria però c'era
un fake me distrutto di polizia o
purissima en onofri turno non posso più
fare niente se non prendere questo gol a
ricordarmi che io sono io e la palla
come non entro quest'estate in pallet si
è la mia vita e la mia vita la mia vita
07 del club monarchico consigliato
malissimo
ok va bene spettacolo di nuovo
avrei preferito segnare in quell altra
circostanza però che va bene anche così
la finta che questa l'ha imparata con la
prima è entrata come doveva entrare
va bene ma mi sono anche a gatto nel
montana
niente niente bello bello
bisogna prenderla è bello buona vecchia
cina per queste palle
ok o fuori buffon attenzione no ma nasce
un gas come dove stiamo per l'energia
vigile attenzione nel male
niente
davvero troppo ovviamente il ladro ci ho
provato lo stesso lo testo modesto corre
in bagno
va bene l'ultima copia della fine
ok io mi sono 20 questa è l'anima
successi di così non potevo fare
lo giuro che i ragazzi questo era uno
che uno infatti se notate secondo me se
mi impegna un po di più giusto quel gol
di differenza che ha diviso le nostri
punteggi il caso faremo un altro 1 v1
nel frattempo iscritti al cai lasciato
bel mi piace e noi come sempre ci diamo
anno provino bella ragazzi
[Musica]